pietro bocelli is a 27 year old who has
a phd in mechanical engineering
while he was teaching a course a student
discovered that he's also a model
this got picked up in the western media
and he's quickly dubbed the world's
hottest math teacher
alex bellows at the guardian recently
interviewed pietro
two of the questions i found interesting
were he asked whether pietro knew any
mathematical party tricks and whether he
could calculate 43 by 67 in his head
it turned out he didn't know any tricks
and that's a shame
so in this video i'm going to teach you
how you can do 43 by 67 in your head
using some of the methods i've already
taught
the first method
is a video i made about how you can
multiply two numbers that are close to
each other
the procedure is to look at the average
of the two numbers and square it and
subtract the difference from the average
and square that
43 and 67 have an average of 55 and both
numbers have a difference of 12 from 55
so we can compute the product as 55
squared minus 12 squared
now we know 12 squared is 144
but what's 55 squared
in another method i've taught you can
square numbers in the 50s very easily
the method is to add
the difference from 50 to 25 that
becomes the leading digits of your
answer
and then the last two digits are the
square of the difference from 50.
55 has a difference of 5 from 50
so 25 plus 5 is 30 and 5 squared is 25
therefore 55 squared is 30 25.
there is another method you could use
you can also square a number ending in
five what you do is you look at the tens
digit and you multiply it by one more
than itself
you then append 25 at the end of the
number
here the tens digit is 5
so 5 times 6 is 30
we then append 25 to get 55 squared is
30 25.
putting it all together we have 43 times
67 is 55 squared minus 12 squared
which is then 30 25 minus 144
which we can then come to 28.81
so while each of these tricks i've
taught you may have seemed like it was
solving a very specific problem the joy
of these mental math tricks is that you
can put them together and solve
otherwise problems that you would never
be able to solve in your head very
easily
if you liked some of these methods you
should definitely check out my book the
best mental math tricks it'll help you
look like a genius at party
i cover all sorts of methods including
squaring numbers multiplying numbers
dividing numbers and each method is
accompanied by complete mathematical
proof so you can even learn the methods
to prove why these math tricks work
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my video i make videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions which you can follow
on facebook google plus and patreon you
can also catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker
and you can check out all my books
there's a link in the video description
thanks for watching